et on ouvre maintenant une page culture
une bande dessinée rien que sur
Versailles elle vient d'être publiée ce
mercredi 26 septembre elle s'intitule Le
Crépuscule des rois tout cela est bien
normal Johanna souris a rencontré pour
nous les causes de cette bande dessinée
allons faire des bulles à Versailles
Eric Adam et Didier convar merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes les auteurs de ce
premier album le crépuscule du roi j'ai
envie de vous demander où est-ce que
nous nous trouvons actuellement et bien
nous sommes dans le château de
Versailles devant la chapelle royale à
côté du salon d'Hercule
pour écrire cet album parce que vous
êtes le
ici pour un peu vous inspirer des lieux
oui on a eu la chance d'avoir des
visites particulières pour effectivement
nous aspirer des lieux et puis voir
surtout des endroits qui ne sont pas
forcément présentés au public le château
de Versailles on a une image du château
de Versailles qui est assez simple après
tout on voit la galerie des Glaces on
voit les appartements du roi mais il y a
derrière d'autres appartements des cours
intérieurs et toute une vie qui foisonne
dans le château de Versailles c'est vrai
qu'on est très très souvent
effectivement dans ce lieu c'est la
première chaque fois que tous deux vous
écrivez sur Versailles sur Versailles
oui absolument nous allons faire trois
albums sur le sujet trois albums qui
seront indépendants le fil rouge sera le
château ce sera la seule le seul lien
entre les trois albums qui pourront se
lire tout à fait indépendamment alors
pourquoi ce choix comment vous est venu
cette idée c'est une collection que
développe les éditions Glénat qui est
une collection sur les grands lieux du
patrimoine il y a eu un album sur le
Mont-Saint-Michel sur Carnac en Bretagne
un autre sur le Panthéon sur le pendule
de Foucault et là donc il va y avoir ce
troisième album sur le château de
Versailles qui ne pouvait pas être évité
dans le cadre de cette collection
avant de d'entamer Versailles quelles
étaient vos thèmes de prédilection
c'est l'histoire lesotérisme et tout ce
qui touche aux sociétés secrètes et aux
religions
donc faire ça effectivement c'est une
petite récréation dans ma dans mon
histoire dans mon histoire de scénariste
mais d'un autre côté Versailles est un
petit peu ésotérique aussi parce que
Versailles montre beaucoup d'or beaucoup
de lumière mais il y a une ombre dans
Versailles et c'est ce qui intéresse les
scénaristes c'est savoir ce qui se passe
dans l'ombre
j'ai cru savoir que vous étiez plus
western j'ai envie de dire
western peut-être pas mais mais moi
effectivement je suis moins mystique et
spirituel que Didier mais j'aime aussi
beaucoup les les histoires qui ont un
cadre historique et dans lesquels on
puisse développer des intrigues un peu
un peu feuilletonesque nous sommes tous
les deux des grands admirateurs des
romans à la Dumas et voilà c'est ce
qu'on essaye de faire quand on écrit
ensemble
que va-t-on découvrir dans ce premier
album ce premier album en fait le
concept sera donc de faire trois albums
à trois époques différentes pour montrer
que le château dans le présent dans le
passé et dans le futur et toujours le
même est toujours là et il y a toujours
autant de force symboliques et mythique
et celui là commence dans le futur donc
je vais pas dévoiler l'intrigue mais on
montre qu'il y a une sorte de perd
Durance d'éternité dans la façon de
vivre au château mais qui cache des
choses peut-être bien plus grave
oui j'ai un petit peu feuilleté l'album
je n'ai pas pu encore le lire mais on
voit ça rappelle un peu la
science-fiction est-ce que je me trompe
et bien nous allons vous surprendre
effectivement on commence sans une
histoire classique traditionnelle il y a
un roi vous connais pas trop son numéro
mais on va tout se passe bien les nobles
font des histoires de nobles les
chambrières font des histoires de
Chabrières et puis il y a quelque chose
qui se passe d'un seul coup on ressent
des petits anachronismes et des petites
choses anormales dans le dans l'histoire
ça ne devrait pas se passer comme ça
surtout que après tout les serveurs
s'appellent tous Robert et des Roberts
qui servent les roberts partout il se
rebaire de temps en temps ils ont plutôt
une allure de robot et ce château on ne
peut pas en sortir si on passe les
grilles de ce château on rentre dans un
univers extrêmement angoissant
extrêmement anxiogène sommes-nous
vraiment dans le château de Versailles à
cette époque là on va pas en dire plus
juste peut-être rappeler les dates de
sortie c'est le premier album qui est
sorti le crépuscule du roi suivront
ensuite
les titres
il faut que je les regarde mon anti
sèche mais bon alors le titre moi je me
souviens pas tout à fait des titres
parce que nous sommes sur le scénario
l'ombre de la reine c'est le tome 2
bravo merci Eric qui a une mémoire
beaucoup plus jeune que la mienne et le
troisième on va encore réfléchir sur le
titre on sait que c'est l'histoire de
Molière et du Masque de fer et on
réfléchit encore sur le titre
merci beaucoup
voilà c'était
jojoannaristes du crespuscule du roi
c'est une trilogie c'est le premier
album de la trilogie